on dirait quand on s'intéresse un peu à
l'est de la guerre économique et aux
théoriciens de la guerre économique ce
que vous êtes devenus tous les deux on a
l'impression tous les pays sont toujours
nationaliste ans qu'ils considèrent
leurs économies les américains se sont
montrés très nationaliste dans les
années 80 90 quand le japon les menaçait
les européennes notamment quand et
japonais ont commencé à mettre le pied à
hollywood les américains sont devenus
très nationaliste et le sont les chinois
le sont les japonais sont ils n'aient
pas de manière peut-être nous alors
est-ce que vous avez l'air de dire comme
les européens vont regarder ce qui s'est
passé dans la fusion alstom siemens
c'est eux-mêmes les européens qui ont
décidé à partir d'un droit de la
concurrence qui date des années 90 ans
que la chine n'était pas rentré à l'om
c'est qui a dit ben non il ne faut pas
construire un géant européen des
transports ferroviaires
alors que évidemment en face la chine y
un géant qui arrivent et qui va tout
bouleverser
donc oui l'absence de réflexion
stratégique le fait que l'europe se soit
toujours dit on s'est construite sur
notre norme qui est la paix surtout ne
pas parler c'est tabou de puissance ne
pas parler d'affrontement et c'est nous
c'est la paix cette paix là va nous
permettre d'influencer le monde non ce
n'est plus suffisant aujourd'hui il faut
penser l'affrontement économique alors
moi je suis pas guerrier économique mais
je dis qu'il faut le penser pour
comprendre les impacts de cet
affrontement économique et franchement
il ya un continuum entre les gilet jaune
et l'absence de pensée sur la guerre
économique et parce que c'est les dégâts
c'est le résultat de l'absence de pensée
c'est les gilets jaunes c'est le fait
qu'on des intrus un désindustrialise la
france on désindustrialise l'europe etc
tout ça c'est un continuum qui va
falloir penser aujourd'hui est remarqué
le aujourd'hui l'europe est en train de
l'asthme et l'europe reparle de
protection des citoyens leur propre de
politique industrielle ce qui était
tabou il ya encore deux ans donc oui ils
sont plus sont en train de prendre
contient
[Musique]